the best way to look at this is when our
sex hormones will respond to changes in
insulin so here's a great example
pcos pcos is the number one hormonal
problem for women
and it is directly connected to insulin
resistance you take a woman with pcos
and you get her insulin under control
you get her detoxing those two things
because phthalates also plays a big part
into pcos and you can change pcos i've
seen it a thousand times but you gotta
get her insulin sensitive because she
needs to be insulin sensitive to get
those foundational hormones under
control here's the trick is that above
that is cortisol so you take a woman
who's like super stressed out and she's
trying to get insulin sensitive and she
can't because cortisol forces us to hold
on to more insulin hold on to more
glucose to become more uh in that
fight-or-flight stage
and then above that is oxytocin so
oxytocin is the hormone that makes
everything better and it balances
cortisol it balances insulin and it'll
balance those sex hormones so when we're
looking at to answer your original
question when we're looking at hormones
they're flipping moving targets like you
know right as you are experiencing yeah
so you get estrogen in balance and then
all of a sudden you go on a three to six
month like
binge with your food and insulin gets
off and now estrogen's gonna start to
tank
you get cortisol under control you
decide to change your lifestyle and
maybe you're doing better and all of a
sudden progesterone starts to balance
out so each one of these hormones
influence the impact on the other ones
which is why they are so
hard to balance because they're always
changing
yeah well what are the main factors to
balance them then like if you were to
have buckets like how many would you
need and what would they be yeah like of
like food fasting emotional stability
like what are those things yeah so i
really say there are five things that
women have to do so the first is fasting
and here's here's the way i approach
fasting and it's so different for women
than men so that's the first thing i
want to point out right i have a lot of
questions about women versus men okay
for sure this is a huge one because when
i first learned fasting at 43
what i noticed was my mental clarity
went through the roof like at my 3
o'clock dip in the afternoon gone my
sleeping was good my night sweats went
away like all these really weird
perimenopausal symptoms cleared up just
from the first one which is fasting and
it's because i finally got insulin under
control
but for and we can go into this later
but for women estrogen loves when you
fast
progesterone doesn't progesterone it
like because right because it's
progesterone right and we need
progesterone to feel like a normal human
and not kill everybody so
but progesterone is so influenced by
cortisol
so when we do too much fasting we start
to tank cortisol or we start to elevate
cortisol and tank progesterone so as
women we can go into this in a moment as
women we need to know when to fast and
when not to fast
that and men don't have to think about
that right men can just fast whenever
they want and from what i understand
women can fall into the men category
once they finish menopause and they are
out of their cycles well said okay amen
yes which is is awesome and
let's talk about
the menopausal perimenopausal woman
it's nor
a healthy age to go into menopause is
about 52 somewhere between 52 and 55.
okay most women and this was me at 4 30
at 43
many women i shouldn't say met most many
women are going into full-on menopause
at 43 and mid-40s
and
when you do that what happens now is you
set yourself up for the diseases that a
lot of women get later on cardiovascular
disease
the breast cancer breast cancer ovarian
cancer
so
with fasting what i'm trying to help
women see is that when you learn how to
fat when to fast for estrogen and when
not to fast for progesterone and you
learn like a rhythm with fasting and you
get yourself insulin sensitive you will
prolong your period which is fabulous
and it'll put you into menopause at the
appropriate time to prevent disease okay
well how do we do it
there you go so that that's that's
fasting the um the other four ones that
i think every woman needs to think about
and i don't know if you know this one
this one blew my mind is that we're not
meant to eat the same way throughout
every day of our cycle
yeah to some degree because i um have
become friends with elisa vitti who
wrote in the flow and woman code and
because i had cycle issues and my whole
story doesn't is is its own thing but
anyway it drew me into the book and so i
then started to learn sort of like a
more of a rhythm to like certain foods
that help with estrogen follicles
progesterone like and and and just
allowing your body to get into its site
into a rhythm and so there's the sort of
like four cycles of food per month
obviously that correlate with
correlate with which part of the month
you're in right which let's just stop
there for a moment like i know in my 13
year old gym class where i was taught
puberty that there was
nothing
talked about like you might want to carb
load a little more before your your
cycle starts you might want to do a
little less carbs when you actually your
cycle actually starts like
nobody taught us that no no no no
there's like there's no real teaching on
the fundamental things that really
affect you in life like you know your
cycle uh relationships
self-improvement like your emotions your
trauma
right there's so many things we don't
learn about in school like we're being
taught like proofs and geometry and
[ __ ] we'll never ever need right but you
know thank you into real life and we're
like
i don't know
it's a no man's land so thank you for
sharing this stuff with us
right right well so this is my big once
i figured out how to fast and eat around
my hormones that's at 43.
i was like wait a second why did nobody
teach this to me at 13 and why didn't i
learn this in my 20s like where was this
education missing which is so such a
huge part of why i'm just trying to wake
women up to help them see this
which is amazing so if there was a quick
way to say like what those sort of
eating patterns are is that easy enough
to give us some tips on that phase of
your cycle what i've done is i created
something called the fasting cycle and i
took a 30-day period and i mapped out
when a woman's hormones were coming in
and what food and fast we can time to it
we even by the way can time our exercise
i don't know with the lisa yeah yeah
there's food exercise there's emotion
sex like every category gets covered so
every category i mean all the biohacking
cold plunges like are we supposed to do
those all the time these are all
questions i've tried to map to the
hormones so
so this is the way it works on day one
we have this plummet of all our hormones
so the first day you bleed and you
probably since you've talked to alyssa
you know um that our hormones plummet
now those first couple of days estrogen
is going to start to ramp back up and
over the next 10 days estrogen slowly
builds
estrogen loves us to be insulin
sensitive so when after the first couple
of days are over with our cycle like
into day three we can do keto we can go
into longer fasts all of that is only
going to benefit estrogens production so
i always think like we have women in our
community that they flip and love
three-day water fuss have you done one
i've done 36 hours
oh awesome okay so you could do a
three-day
it it's we're gonna talk about hunger at
some point in time it's a spiritual
experience
so yeah at three so these women you know
they people love to do the 36 48 three
day and because it makes them feel so
good but it's easier are you saying it's
easier then too
it's way easier yeah way easier good
point
so you that first 10 days longer fast
less carbs that's going to help estrogen
then we go into ovulation day about day
11 to 15. well you've got estrogen at
her peak you've got
testosterone coming in for the first
time let's just talk about that how
biologically amazing we are that
testosterone comes in during ovulation
that is that is super smart of our body
we want to get it on yeah right exactly
as we're we're
we're supposed to during ovulation which
is like there's a tip from the men of
the group
so but then we need to help break down
those hormones so during ovulation less
fasting
i even find people who are doing keto at
that time not a great choice because
testosterone needs a little more glucose
in our system
so more of like working on your
microbiome we have a whole set of
bacteria that break estrogen down break
our hormones down so you want to bring
carbs back up during ovulation and but
nature's carbs this isn't go sit on the
couch and eat a you know box of pizza
and a tub of ice cream so and so you
want to bring your carb load up and fast
a little less
then we come out of
our ovulation window and we have another
dip of hormones we can fast again then
day 16 we go keto again 16 through 18
we're golden but then progesterone
decides to come in around day 19
and that's the moment we need to chill
out a little more we need to bring
glucose up because here's the thing
about progesterone in order to make
progesterone your brilliant body
actually becomes more insulin resistant
the week before your period
so that it can make progesterone it
purposely blunts insulin from getting
into the cell so you can have more
glucose to make progesterone
that we should have been taught
so there's a reason you crave carbs
there's a reason you want to kind of go
inner and you don't want to be like like
pushing your workouts
you don't want to be raising cortisol
you don't want to be fasting and that
all happens the week before
oh wow
wow yeah that's amazing i mean this is
like
this is we'll change
if this was taught and this is something
we implemented i can't imagine the
benefits in the long term so
we're a generation away from it
you